y
[Música]
italia ya tiene presidente después de
ocho sesiones parlamentarias en las que
no hubo un consenso el actual mandatario
sergio matar el a fue reelegido con la
mayoría de los mil nueve votos posibles
y estará siete años más en el carné
tres estados de eeuu declaran situación
de emergencia por la fuerte tormenta
invernal y algunas ciudades del noroeste
como nueva york se tienen reportes de
más de 30 centímetros de nieve y el
temporal obligó a cancelar cerca de
4.800 vuelos en un solo día
hace 60 años se hizo el primer desfile
del diseñador de modas francés its sun
lu con seis museos de parís celebraron
la conmemoración exponiendo algunos de
sus diseños y es que sanz lugo fue uno
de los primeros en llevar el museo a la
pasarela
buenas noches y bienvenidos de nuevo a
las noticias de france 24 mi nombre es
maría clara calle y comenzamos en italia
porque ya tiene presidente después de
seis días de bloqueo absoluto repetirá
de la jefatura del estado sergio matar
el a tras obtener 759 votos cuando eran
necesarios 505 este veterano político
pensaba retirarse pero finalmente ha
sido el único capaz de desencallar el
bloqueo además es el segundo presidente
en la historia del país que repite
mandato judis muñoz nos informa
a sus 80 años sergio matar el a fue
reelegido presidente para otros 7 años
el veterano político pensaba retirarse
pero los partidos incapaces de llegar a
acuerdos no le han permitido descansar y
ha tenido que desencallar el bloqueo
político italiano así fue su discurso de
aceptación y journey dice dos cosas y
por la elección une a la presidencia de
la república los días difíciles que ha
habido durante la elección presidencial
en un momento de serias emergencias como
la sanitaria la económica y la social
apelan a un sentido de responsabilidad y
a respetar las decisiones tomadas por el
parlamento que responsabiliza para la
elección de mataré la han sido
necesarias ocho votaciones mario draghi
que se ofreció como presidente seguirá
como primer ministro de una coalición de
gobierno heterogénea todas las fuerzas
excepto la ultraderecha de hermanos de
italia aplaudieron la continuidad del
presidente de la opinión en cambio
pública de mi opinión hoy ha ganado
italia nuestro país se ha fortalecido
con la persona adecuada en el puesto
indicado
en la calle también reconocen a matar el
a pero la clase política no queda bien
parada
es un fracaso que repite un hombre que
dijo en varias ocasiones que lo mejor
era avanzar sin él pero matar el a sigue
siendo mejor que cualquier otro
candidato en medio de murcia al pri
cantidad
miembro de la centroizquierda del
partido demócrata sergio matar el la
ocupó distintos ministerios fue juez de
la corte constitucional y es considerado
uno de los mejores presidentes de la
historia de la república ahora pensaba
dedicarse a su familia pero el ajedrez
político italiano le pidió por favor que
continuase y el camión de mudanzas que
llevaba sus cosas a una nueva casa tuvo
que dar media vuelta en portugal también
hay elecciones este domingo se
celebrarán los comicios anticipados en
los que los dos candidatos más
opcionados están empatados en las
últimas encuestas por un lado del primer
ministro antónio costa de
centroizquierda se niega a hacer
alianzas con el colectivo de extrema
derecha llega mientras que el líder de
la oposición ruiz río afirma que su
partido los socialdemócratas le darán un
nuevo rumbo al país ibérico la
ultraderecha podría crecer en estas
elecciones como ya ha ocurrido en europa
vamos ahora hasta turquía del mandatario
reyerta y verdad destituyó al presidente
del instituto de estadísticas luego de
que éste anunciara que la inflación
había alcanzado un máximo histórico de
36 por ciento el funcionario despedido
es site verdad de ser turquía en frente
a la peor crisis monetaria en los 19
años de gobierno de erdogán el
presidente ha sido criticado por
sustituir a tres gobernadores del banco
central y al ministro de finanzas
de noticias de eeuu los estados de nueva
york nueva jersey y más massachusetts
decretaron situación de emergencia por
la tormenta invernal que azota el
noroeste del país las ráfagas de viento
y la nieve son tantas que las
autoridades recomendaron evitar los
viajes mientras que más de 4800 vuelos
se cancelaron hoy según flightaware
rafael pérez nos cuenta
impresionantes imágenes satelitales que
muestran la magnitud de la ola invernal
que afecta a eeuu
fuertes nevadas y tormentas golpean el
noreste del país según el servicio
meteorológico nacional se espera que
caigan de 30 a 60 centímetros de nieve y
soplan ráfagas de más de 100 kilómetros
por hora
esta es una tormenta muy seria muy seria
nos hemos estado preparando para esto
esto podría poner en riesgo la vida y
queremos asegurarnos de que tomamos
todas las medidas que creemos que eran
necesarias incluso comenzando con la
declaración de emergencia
el alcalde de nueva york instó a sus
ciudadanos a no movilizarse
pero escuché hoy de monos quedémonos
'new jersey' y boston también se sumaron
al estado de emergencia sin embargo
algunos entusiastas ven con otros ojos
el fenómeno metereológico tan pronto
como vimos que hay una tormenta de nieve
o lo que sea supe que quería estar aquí
porque amo la nieve crecí en el sur no
estoy acostumbrada a la nieve así que
esto es increíble en este contexto más
de 6000 vuelos fueron suspendidos todos
los vuelos han sido congelados hoy pero
tuvimos suerte de llegar ayer esta es
una de las tormentas más fuertes que han
azotado la zona en 1978 un fenómeno
similar paralizó nueva inglaterra
causando la muerte a una decena de
personas y provocando el bloqueo de las
principales carreteras por una semana
una rama de crudo ocurrió en ecuador el
viernes tras una nueva rotura de un
oleoducto en la amazonía dentro de una
zona montañosa amenazada por el proceso
de erosión regresiva del río coca
concretamente la empresa privada de
oleoductos de crudos pesados que opera
la tubería reveló que el incidente se
debió en parte al terreno a las fuertes
lluvias en el área de piedra fina
previamente el ecologista fernando
cortez nos explicó qué consecuencias
podría traer este accidente
bueno definitivamente este es un
fenómeno multidimensional no se ha
registrado como bien señala este a
partir de un proceso de la opción
regresiva natural y un socavón de tierra
pero esto responde a su vez a una
historia de una pésima gestión pública
alrededor del control ambiental y
también es una respuesta estructural de
cierta forma en el sentido de un modelo
económico insostenible e irresponsable a
partir de eso tenemos dos dimensiones
fundamentales de afectación por un lado
la dimensión ambiental teniendo en
cuenta que es un lugar de sensibilidad
ecológica con un alto nivel de
biodiversidad y por otro lado una
dimensión social que tiene que ver con
la salud con la afectación en cuanto a
la contaminación del agua y a la
soberanía alimentaria de las poblaciones
y de las comunidades aledañas
principalmente de pueblos originarios
y para terminar este 29 de enero se
conmemora el aniversario número 60 del
primer desfile del diseñador de moda
francés it sun lugo para celebrar los
seis museos de parís expusieron sus
diseños junto a los cuadros que le
sirvieron de inspiración veamos
un vestido de yves al nuevo junto al
cuadro de pablo picasso que lo inspiró
sanz luego fue uno de los primeros en
llevar el museo a la pasarela a los 29
años el diseñador francés confecciona un
vestido que revolucionó la moda dando
vida a una de las composiciones de la
línea del artista holandés piet mondrian
[Música]
y añade una dimensión a la obra de
mondrian porque da movimiento a formas
que fueron creadas para ser estáticas y
ese es realmente el aspecto visionario
de lo que hizo
vestidos con los diseños de sant luego
las personas dan vida a las obras de
arte los bordados confieren a esta
chaqueta con forma de girasol la textura
empastada típica de la obra de van gogh
mientras que el estilo pixelado de este
cuadro de alan ya que se convierte en
una serie de patrones geométricos
el arte europeo no fue la única
inspiración de sant luego a finales de
los años 60 en sus viajes a marruecos
descubrió colores vivos y materiales
como los collares de madera y la rafia y
salió un diseño este vestido en 1967
para la colección bambara que rendía
homenaje al arte africana vemos que la
modernidad es esencial para ello y la
encontró en el arte africano una mezcla
de tradición y líneas elegantes la
temporada en rosa sanz lugo también era
conocido por sus siluetas largas y
andróginas el mismo era un hábil
ilustrador la casa que compartía con su
marido pierre marie era su propio mini
museo lleno de obras que habían
coleccionado juntos saludo deja un
legado de una estética duradera la cual
consideraba más importante que la moda
si para este caso lo que importa es el
estilo no la moda porque la moda pasa
pero el estilo perdura
[Música]
la obra de ibsen logo ha influenciado en
generaciones de diseñadores que siguen
con jugando a su moda con una alta dosis
de arte
y con este homenaje al diseñador its en
lugo despedimos nuestro noticiero los
invitamos a que sigan conectados a
nuestra programación en france24
[Música]